music is the soundtrack of the soul
and that's how i've always looked at it
just like tears are the the expression
of words we can't articulate
and i look at music as being the
soundtrack to the soul so i've always
wanted to make music that would help
people how did you get into music man
how did it start for you when you're
coming up where does the music hit you
first in your life
my mother was probably like
the sad part of the story is my mother
always struggled with mental health
issues and addiction and she didn't
leave much at all when i was a kid she
was a recluse she never really left the
house and uh
she would like her making it to the
kitchen table was kind of like a big
deal you know yeah and you'd walk in the
house and mom would be at the kitchen
table and she'd have a cigarette lit and
she'd be sitting on a wood chair indian
style right there in the kitchen back
when you could smoke it when back when
restaurants had smoking sections smoking
inside places was a thing you know and
she'd be there smoking a cigarette and
she'd have a record plan
and she'd just have her eyes closed and
i just i could tell that the music was
doing something to her man
like i just remember watching her and
thinking man this music's like
whatever that is is
helping her you know or she'd play like
bette miller the rose and cry
i could i could still hear in my head
play this in my funeral to this day if
you play bette midler the rose right now
i might tear up and she plays my funeral
jelly place my funeral baby jason she
just smoked cigarette
and i just remember thinking man i want
to make people feel the way this makes
my mother feel
that's the songwriting aspect of it
right that was what
ignited the songwriter in me
now the influences are cool because i
was the baby right i was the youngest
how many uh two brothers one sister and
my sister who she's still with to this
day was within so she's been with this
man 30 something years he pretty much
lived with us from her high school years
up so i say i had three brothers two
brothers a brother-in-law that lived
with us and a sister and we always had
some broke cousin on the couch or some
broke family and you know in the living
room with blow up mattresses or
something this was just like future
convict yeah this is our current convict
or somebody on the run from the police
we had that kind of a house when i got
in the car with anybody because i was
the baby i had no [ __ ] control of the
radio dial i was the last [ __ ]
that got to pick the radio oh yeah right
it was so important you guys who got to
pick up who got to pick the radio right
i had one brother named scott that's the
middle older that was a straight
gangster rap guy like tupac biggie like
gangster gang the gangster the more
gangster the better what was he dating
white chicks still or how gangster was
he i mean no he was everywhere
his dick didn't discriminate
yeah we get in the car and like all
these different radio stations will play
so like one brother be gangster rap my
sister listen like nothing but metallica
or stone temple pilots yeah for sure
like [ __ ] nirvana when they first
came out this was all oh yeah and then i
had another brother listen like super
hip-hop [ __ ] like biz marquee kind of
[ __ ]
you know what i mean
yeah and then dad would listen to either
jazz or back then like singer songwriter
stuff like james taylor jim croche
my mother listened to motown oldies and
like outlaw country music damn so it's
like every room i'd walk into or every
[ __ ] everywhere i'd go it'd be some
different music playing so when people
like dude you kind of do all kinds of
music i'm like i'm a [ __ ] human
jukebox man i grew up in a you know i
didn't get to pick a music i liked and
get to play it because i didn't [ __ ]
you know everybody else had their genre
of music in their world but me
i didn't have like a place i could go
listen to what i wanted right right
right i just had to listen to whatever
[ __ ] room i walked in yeah that's
funny the younger brother is kind of you
kind of that that ear victim bro you
know it's like whatever you kind of you
start to get into whatever anybody else
is into that's i never thought about
that the older brother really gets to
pick the radio and that kind of shapes
the younger brother a little bit sure
it's like if my brother's listening to
uh dr dre then i'm all drained up i'm
buying that t-shirt with the weeds
and when he switches to nirvana dude i'm
you know i'm cutting my wrist but not
with sharp silverware yeah yeah i didn't
get to get in the car and be like i
really want to listen to 107.5 the river
nobody gave a [ __ ] what i want to listen
to you know like we didn't know you
could talk i tell you the first cassette
tape i ever got given
i got all these gifts for christmas and
then they were like we got one last gift
from you and this is from your bro this
is from your brothers and sisters i was
like oh this is probably the coolest
gift ever and they gave me a little
bitty package and it was a cassette tape
and it was rex and effects rump shaker
yeah
and i was like this is gangster and i
remember at that moment it was something
that was finally mine because they some
mama had bought me a boom box
and daddy bought me a boom box but
nobody i didn't have anything to play in
it yet yeah so then my brother and they
did the coolest thing besides that then
this then they when they hand me the rex
and effects tape then they handed me
five blank cassette tapes
i said what are these for and they were
like we're going to show you how to
record songs off the radio
you remember this era oh right when you
put the cassette tape in listen for all
of y'all that want to know how old i am
i'm that [ __ ] old top
times yeah you go to the top ten and
you'd wait and wait for the perfect
moment for the song to start then you'd
hit the play and record button you gotta
get it just right because you didn't
wanna hear the radio dj or the skip you
wanna just decide that you stop right
there yeah and you play it for one more
second so there was a space between the
two songs
and then you'd hit it again you know are
you calling requests a song that wasn't
popular yet you'd have to wait for hours
for them to play it they're like who's
this donkey and they taught me that so i
started making like mixed cassette tapes
and i knew i was on to something
different then because like i'd get in
the car and find out i got a cassette
tape everybody we don't care about you
can set her but please play it and it
would like go from like rap to something
else and the brother's like what the
[ __ ] is up like well shelby taught me
about this song so everybody got happy
so you really were you really were like
a jukebox yeah oh to this day man you
play very few songs that i'm not like
yeah i know that er how did you get into
the music dan
i was just
i started writing raps young just
because i didn't think i had a cool
voice to sing you know and nobody in the
family sang to teach me to sing so
i would write like raps and that was
obviously like
i don't know how much that we caught
earlier but that was the language of the
community hip-hop was the language of
the neighborhood you know super mixed
community i grew up like you
you know what i'm saying like it always
is a poor neighborhood man it's really
because black [ __ ] is cool usually
so it's like black [ __ ] always is the
cool [ __ ] right 100 no
it's
to this day
hip-hop has influenced every genre of
music on earth
for other people won't admit it or not i
hear it the most in country music yeah i
mean i hear hip-hop melodies hip-hop
drums 808 that is just so prevalent in
country music but
you know hip-hop was the language of the
community so
that was kind of what i got into first
not freestyle at tables and in juvenile
freestyle battle people i fell in love
with songwriting through the process of
writing raps
i immediately i was boxed into being a
freestyle rapper okay and i was like i
don't want to be known for that so i
started writing like songs
and all of my choruses were really
soulful and i'd wrap the verses i had a
song called
you pull up rat jelly roll riding all
alone and i had this record called
riding all alone and it was really slow
and being a little white first of all
the white from three six mafia you
probably remember
yeah
perkins lower tabs still one of my best
friends to this day and when i first
came from memphis huh yeah yeah he's
memphis as [ __ ] too when i first came
home from jail we did a song together
and juicy j and dj paul ended up 36
mafia producing an album with me white
and a guy named b peasy but
outside of the first song i put out with
him i started putting out these super
like soulful joints like this
uh maybe go to like the minute mark or
something i just want you to hear the
course so you can kind of get a feel for
where i'm coming from here
[Music]
and see this was released in 2010
[Music]
right so this is you know [ __ ] 12
years ago right
i just keep on smoking like [ __ ] it i'm
prepared to die say your prayer cause
lord if you're there
watch this check this out
[Music]
yeah but it's like this you know 12 13
years ago right because if it weren't
yeah that would be good now that that
that would be good and i mean that's
good now yeah so then i didn't realize i
was singing that chorus
right you know what i mean like i didn't
register to me that i was singing
because i wouldn't like open up and sing
it you know what i mean so i kind of
like did this like
talk sing thing because i wasn't
confident in my voice so i've kind of
always knew
and there's something else i'm glad i
got to show this to a platform as big as
yours because
the therapeutic music that i make now
that's so personal has always been my
approach to music
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two options
watch one this one or this one